[音楽]
deb 4
[拍手]
思い出してみてください
みなさんは子どものころどんなことにワクワクしていましたか
皆さんは今
わくわくすることはありますか
僕は子供の頃空想するのが大好きでした
自分の頭の中で
こうだったらいいなぁとか
こういうことなんじゃないかなーとか
繰り返し空想していました
back to the future という映画をご覧になった事がある方は覚え
ていらっしゃるかもしれません
タイムパラドックスという言葉が出てきます
あれって
何なんですかねぇ
過去の自分とあってはいけない
あってしまうとタイムパラドックスが起こってしまう
と言われていますが実際には映画の中でタイムパラドックスは起きません
なので僕は子供の頃それがすごく気になって
タイムパラドックスが起こったどうなるんだろう
実際に過去の自分とあったら
何か面白いことが起こるんじゃないかな
あれこれあれこれ
空想していました
僕は今福岡であのラボというクリエイティブの会社をしています
僕たちが作った時空間の尻尾というアート作品は子供の頃のそんなワクワクを形にした
ものです
5秒前の自分と同じ空間にいるような体験ができます
例えば
5秒前の自分と握手をしてみたり
あるいは未来の自分を蹴ってみたり
というような体験をすることができます
時間は目に見えないものですがこのように同じ空間に過去の自分を映し出すことで時間
の軌跡を見ることができます
時間と空間を合わせた時空間という概念は20世紀初頭
アインシュタインの先生をしたこともあるヘルマンミンコフスキーという数学者が
考え出しました
時間時空間という言葉やそこから生まれたパラレルワールドという言葉を聞いたことが
ある方も多いと思います
いまも多くの人をワクワクさせてくれるテーマです
僕は科学館や美術館博物館といった文化施設が大好きです
学校へ行くと教科書を渡されて知識や技術を学ぶことができました
でもそれらが実際に世界とどうつながっているのかということは分かりませんでした
文化施設に行くとそこには僕をワクワクさせてくれるものがある
そしてその先には常に知識や技術があるんだということに気がつきます
それらは興味が湧けば自然とたどり着くものなんです
メイクが2歳ぐらいの頃僕が喋りかけると僕の口元をじーっと見つめてもごもご
モゴモゴ
口の中で繰り返している様子を見て
凄く感動しました
僕たちが今しゃべることができるのも人から教わったからではなくて僕たちが喋りたい
人と話し合いたい
親とコミュニケーションをとりたいというコーチ身によるものなんだと確信しました
僕たちが
科学館的手法と呼んでいるアプローチはこのように
理論を与えて
実践につなげるのではなくて
実戦を通して議論への好奇心を与えるというアプローチです
ボクたちが学生のとき
九州好青年館学館というちょっとふざけた名前の
自主企画のイベントをやっていました
これは
自分たちの体験型のアート作品をただ展示するだけではなくて
それらがどういう仕組みで動いているのか
あるいはどういうプロセスでそれらを作ったのかというのを一緒に展示することであっ
なるほどこういう風になってたんだというのが分かるというコンセプトのアート展でし
た
それから10年が経って
僕たちはここ福岡市科学館のオープニングに携わることができそして一部の展示を製作
することができました
基本展示室やキッズスペースに僕たちの作品が置いてあります
発見の壁は
基本展示室の入口に置いてある体験型の展示です
入口に置かれるものとしてどういうものがいいだろうと思って
何か準備運動のようなもの
理解を促すのではなくて興味を与えて
高
感受性を高めるようなものを目指そうと考えました
文字による説明は一切なく
科学の歴史をテーマに壁画が描かれています
そして
一部の会に触れるとアニメーションが飛び出します
一人でも多くの人がこの発見の壁に触れて自分なりの謎を見つけ出すことができれば
凄く嬉しいです
これって何なんだろう
どういう風に動いてるんだろう
謎はいつも人にワクワクを与えてくれます
そして面白いのは謎に対するアプローチは人それぞれで無数にあるということです
時空間に対する興味から数学者や科学者になる人もいれば
小説を書いたり音楽を作ったり part 作品を作る人だっているんです
大切なのは
謎解くことそのものではなく
それをワクワクを大きくすることは口を育てることにあります
今では謎を解くことそのものはそんなに難しいことではないのかもしれません
スマートフォンを開くと
すぐに情報にアクセスすることができる
でも注意してください
それは同時に自分の中のワクワクの種を一つ減らすことでもあるんです
僕は昔
ネッシーのテレビ番組が大好きでした
ネッシーはいるのかどんな形をしているんだ誰が見つけるんだろう
でも
いつの頃からかネッシーはいないということになってしまって
これは僕は人類最大の損失の一つだと思ってるんですけど
あれだけの人が熱心のな通って
テレビ番組を作ったり映画を作ったり研究家まで現れて
その中にはもしかしたら
水生生物に興味を持って生物学者になった人とか
地形に興味を持って地質学者になった人だっているかもしれません
その可能性が持つ素晴らしさに比べれば
本当にネッシーはいるのかなんて
すごくちっぽけなことじゃないかなと僕は思います
謎からどんな好奇心をもって
どんな未来を切り拓いていくかは無限の可能性を秘めています
そして
子どもたちは謎を見つけさ見つけたスペシャリストです
好奇心がないこともありません
それを
周りの大人が自分が知っているというだけで可能性を摘んでしまうのはすごくもったい
ないことだなと思います
石川直樹さんという写真家で探検家の方がいらっしゃいます
インタビューする機会があり親に感謝したいこととして
親が
自分を止めないでいてくれたことというようにおっしゃいました
そして子どものときのエピソードを聞かせてくれました
家族で山に彼は釣りに行った時に
川の上流が気になってどうなってるんだろうと一人で歩いていったそうです
その時に
親は自分を止めないでいてくれた
コレは確かに良く考えればすごいことだと思います
親だとやっぱり止めたくなるし
教えたくなる
でも子どもの好奇心を信じて止めない
止めなかった結果その子はワクワクを自分自身の手で育て上げることができ
有名な探検家になることができました
最近ドキドキワクワクすることがなくなったという人がいます
自分の中の可能性をどんどんどんどん摘んでしまった結果世界から好奇心を感じ取る
感受性が低下してしまっているんだと思います
何か新しいものを見つけても
先にやらない理由を考えてしまう
でも
世界は謎に満ちています
ネっ子だけが謎を全てではありません
そして
一つの謎から選び取った洗濯も
無数にある可能性の中のたった一つでしかありません
もうそれは知ってるよというようなことであってももう一度可能性を見つめ直してみ
ましょう
他の人と話し合ってみると意外な可能性に気づくことがあるかもしれません
好奇心を伸ばすことは何も子どもたちだけの特権ではなく僕たちみんなにできること
です
そして好奇心を伸ばすことに慣れればその先にどんな可能性だってあるんだということ
に気がつきます
皆さんは今どんなことにワクワクしていますか
自分の謎を見つけて
新しい未来を作りましょう
ありがとうございます
[拍手]